أي واحد
هذا أعتقد أن هذا سيكون جيدًا ، نعم
لا ، سأحاول أنه سيعطيني
جيدًا المملكة العربية السعودية مليئة بالجواهر الخفية
وإذا كان هناك شخص واحد يعرف
ما يخبئه قطاع السياحة
فهو السياحة  قمت بزيارة نائب الوزير
للمملكة العربية السعودية للحاق
بالأميرة هيفاء السد عندما
تم إطلاق رؤية 2030 في عام 2016 ، وكان الهدف هو
التنويع بعيدًا عن النفط وما هي
الصناعة الأفضل للقيام بذلك من السياحة ، حيث
ساهمنا بنسبة 3٪ في الناتج المحلي الإجمالي
في عام 2018.  نحن نهدف إلى رفع ذلك
إلى 10 بحلول عام 2030 ولكن أيضًا في خلق فرص العمل
وحل البطالة ، لذا فإن السياحة هي
في طليعة جهودنا ، ما
الذي ستقوله سيكون تركيزك الأكبر
في فتح أسواق جديدة
وما هي المنتجات التي أنت  البيع الآن ،
لذا فتحت زيارة السعودية 15
سوقًا دوليًا عبر
الوجهات الرئيسية سواء كانت في الولايات المتحدة
سواء كانت في ألمانيا سواء كانت
في آسيا سواء كان الأمر كذلك فنحن ننفتح في
جميع أنحاء العالم.  g
للتداول ، لذا فقد دخلنا في شراكة على سبيل المثال
مع رحلة إلى حزم التصميم للعملاء الصينيين
عندما يتم فتح السوق الصينية
وعندما تفتح الصين ، لذلك
لدينا على سبيل المثال 80 مرشدًا سياحيًا
تم تدريبهم في لغة الماندرين ،
لدينا 60 مرشدًا سياحيًا آخر لديهم  تم تدريبه باللغة
الألمانية لأننا نعلم أن بعض
الأسواق تحتاج إلى هذه
اللغة وتتطلبها ، لذلك نحن نبني
عروضنا ونصممها
لتناسب منافسة تقسيم العملاء بين
البلدان في المنطقة ، وأقصد في دبي
وجهة ساخنة في كل بلد
أزوره.  إن وضع أنفسهم
يشبه المكان الذي يجب أن تكون فيه ، وهل تشعر
أن هناك صداقة حميمة في المنطقة
فيما يتعلق بالسياحة ، هل تشعر أنه
عليك أن تضع نفسك
وتميز أنفسنا علينا أن نتصرف
بهذه الطريقة لأننا كمنطقة
نحن  مغناطيس للعالم ونحن
أقوى معًا وسأعطيكم
مقارنة مع البيع بالتجزئة حيث
تجد جميع العلامات التجارية الكبيرة التي دائمًا ما تكون
في قطاع واحد لأن  إنهم يدركون أنه عندما
يجتمعون معًا في شريط واحد ،
سيأتي الأشخاص إلى هذا الشريط الواحد مقابل
عندما ينتشرون في جميع أنحاء أنت
تعرف المدينة ، لذلك سأقدم لك هذه
المقارنة معنا كوجهة ، فنحن
أقوى معًا والمنافسة
جيدة  انه صحي